bell
exercice grandeur nature ce matin
d'octobre pour tous les services du plan
orsec
trois bus en bout de piste de l'aéroport
roland garros afin de mettre en scène un
crash aérien
une simulation est essentielle car elle
peut permettre de comprendre les forces
et les faiblesses d'une intervention
collective
alors que les colis doivent placer des
pendulettes 1 et vous passez du national
et puis à décaper le monde en avait 25
de chaque fonctionnaire et puis c'est
bien vous avez installé 25 valant près
de golf à l'entrée du près de la
bretelle golf et on attend les secours
extérieurs dont le commandant ce patient
de secours est fait par une fille
s'appropier qui doit coordonner tous les
moyens le public et privé qui sont mises
à sa disposition pour secourir les gens
donc c'est à travers ce genre d'exercice
que nous travaillons cette coordination
est justement les services vont arriver
au fur et à mesure ils vont permettre ce
cas les par rapport au départ de
l'intervention on ne trouve que des
pompiers nous sommes là pour rodez
toutes les procédures que qui ont été
élaborées dans le cadre des dispositifs
spécifiques orsec aérodrome roland
garros et on est là également pour
appliquer le dispositif spécifique orsec
nombreuses victimes qu'on appelle nos
vies
l'ambiance factice jouée par les élèves
de l'école d'infirmières est pourtant
présente pour les secours alors comment
être ordonnées dans tout ce désordre
au début il ya plus de victimes que de
sauveteurs donc il faut s'adapter à
cette situation donc là on est en phase
de montée en puissance l'ado de secours
qui sont en route ils peuvent pas être
là tout de suite donc les premiers
arrivants qui soit pompier ou médecins
du samu doivent faire face à un plus
grand nombre de victimes qu'ils ont la
capacité de traiter donc il faut qu'ils
s'organisent donc ils sont en train de
s'organiser
ils vont essayer de rassembler les plus
graves dans un endroit un peu plus
protégé les moins graves qui peuvent
marcher vont être regroupés sur une
autre zone pour pouvoir prendre en
charge le mieux possible tous les
patients en fonction de leur degré de
gravité les évacuer vers les hôpitaux de
hauteur
/
classique
je me sens faible
parallèlement à cela les forces de
l'ordre doivent récupérer le maximum
d'informations une action pas toujours
facile
c'est alors une deuxième vague de
secours cette fois extérieur l'aéroport
qui arrivent sur le site
le passage d'information et des tâches
se doit être rapide et précis pariant
feu disloqué en plusieurs parties nathan
extinction au cours moyen de trois
lances nombreuses victimes éparpillées
sur une grande surface
je confirme laurent pour des moyens
extérieurs et déclenchement du plan
orsec dispositif disposition spécifique
à l'europe roland garros ok on suit pas
le regroupement des victimes qui est l
investigation à mi chemin qu'a été la
colonisation m 107 kg 1re risques de
nature à trice de feu selon elle le bus
bleu etc ont été investigués le but
chinois du vin bien ternes
reconnaissance rappelons qu'il ya encore
de nombreuses victimes à la tripartie
d'avion qui encore victimes arrêté le
bus noir
m
grade habituellement en urgence absolue
à l'urgence relative huerre ou impliqués
en fonction ça implique un terme d'edf
implique des délais de d'évacuation qui
sont pas les mêmes laurence absolue bien
évidemment passe en avant l'urgence
relative qu'un gameplay du thorax va
être immédiatement évacué sur un hôpital
quelqu'un qui a une simple blessure de
la cheville sans pronostic vital engagé
pourra être évacués dans un délai
beaucoup plus long et au priorisera les
patients les plus gras sur ça qu'il faut
qu'on ait une idée rapide des plus
graves pouvoir en prendre et à prendre
en charge en première alors bien
évidemment dans ce type de situation il
ya un impact psychologique qui peuvent
faire les personnes qui sont pas blessés
sur le plan physique peuvent être
extrêmement traumatisés sur le plan
psychologique dans le dans les plans de
secours
il y a aussi la mobilisation de
professionnels de psychologues de
psychiatres ce qu'on appelle la cub la
cellule d'urgence médico psychologique
qui va être mobilisée pas au même temps
que les pompiers que le samu parce qu'il
ya toujours un petit peu de délai pour
le son arrivée mais elle va arriver dans
quelques minutes elle prendra en charge
les patients valide mais impliqué sur le
plan psychologique très des victimes va
se passer par là parce que tout passe
par le tout le monde passe par le pma le
pub sera placé logiquement à l'arrière
en 38 heures 38 a eu assez les urgences
absolues qui sont expliquées et
hospitalisés de suite qui sont évacuées
les u r non être soignés ici évacué
après et en a 70 impliqué lacunes c'est
la cellule d'urgence médico
psychologique donc dépendent
l'établissement public de santé mentale
de la réunion et qui est composée de
volontaires qui vont s'y quatre
psychologues infirmiers spécialisés en
santé mentale qui viennent de toute la
réunion
bon eh ben il faut demander des chaises
parce qu'elles sont parties aux pma les
choses vous n'avez pas des petites
chaînes chez vous à nous prêter
fait d'eux des petits quoi vous savez
pour pour faire des petits jeux trois
chaises parti quoi voilà super génial
vous pouvez aller loin les chais ça fait
partie de l'ensemble de
des principes c'est à dire de restaurer
un petit peu la dignité l'humanité c'est
des gens quand ils ont vécu quelque
chose de cet ordre là ils ont
l'impression d'avoir d'avoir tout perdu
jusqu'à leur propre humanité leur propre
dignité une chaise inverse que tout tout
tout ça pour nous c'est le cadre dans
lequel on permet de ré inscrire le sujet
ben du côté du côté de la vie ça peut
paraître anodin mais en même temps c'est
je crois que c'est des choses
essentielles
mais mon car ici les gens qu'ils
arrivent sauf si un ring rascisme il
voulait y sont mis sur les brancards
les gens voient là ils vont repart
quelques excuses à l'avant un petit
hôpital se met en place afin de soigner
les victimes mais également de les
évacuer
mélenchon mélanger pour ne pas déjà vu
oui techniquement si vous mettez là
comme ça non nous impliquer ils sont
plus envahis par le par le passage de
voilà ça serait vraiment super sympa de
votre part parce qu'en fait la la je
pense qu'ils s'aggravent ou là ou là
mais importance de ces simulations c'est
d'apprendre à travailler ensemble
pas facile ce n'est pas facile
constamment chacun des préoccupations
très différentes à des fonctions très
différentes et des façons de penser très
différentes et la question des soins
psychologiques et pas forcément toujours
la priorité dans ce type 2
d'événements pardon de l'autre côté de
la piste bien loin de cette agitation la
vie normale les familles arrivent à
l'aéroport pour récupérer leurs proches
des gens la regardent personne qui a
pris autrement
on n'arrête pas de nous renvoyer à
droite à gauche on sait bien sûr non je
suis c'est bien tu sais un stress pour
vous et tout s'effondre il a de la
cellule et ont roulé mais la successeure
l'absence d'information ou encore leur
véracité
exceet la foule face au personnel de
comptoir qui doit à nouveau gérer et
après de longues minutes
l'autre partie de l'équipe de la cuma
arrive sur le site ya juste ce niveau du
comptoir on les informe de monter dans
la salle et dans la salle il n'y a rien
hormis l'accès au téléphone pour la
préfecture pour avoir des infos
choix des mots voilà nous sommes là on
va vous accompagner dans la salle on va
rester avec nous j'étais en retard aux
victimes
alors nous on est arrivés dès qu'on nous
a appelés donc le pont car nous avons
maintenant j'apprends je trouve
vous savez nous on n'a pas de signes de
violence en tant que psychologue nous
interviendrons véhicule personnel on n'a
pas de gyrophare mais on a un service de
l'urgence 1000 m on n'a pas les mêmes en
ce qu'il faut revoir sa femme ait commis
des passagers arrivent donc mon équipe
alors donné l'information
les deux heures que ça a été ça a été
signalé maintenant nous pouvons pas
faire plus vite maintenant on est là
pour vous déjà comment ça se passe pour
vous balisé
difficile très difficile
il pose plein de questions n'a pas peur
on a pas de formation est important
qu'on puisse savoir cris et qui
identifiait les uns et des autres pour
pouvoir communiquer au plus haut plus
vite pour que dans ce genre de situation
dans ce type de cas les choses puissent
se mettre en place le plus rapidement
possible et de manière la plus
efficiente possible
les familles sont alors regroupés dans
une salle dédiée isolé du grand public
de l'aéroport
la prise en charge peut se faire de la
meilleure des manières
alors pour l'instant la chose à savoir
c'est que il y avait cette salle a été
extrait mis à votre disposition pour que
les premières informations qui arrivent
nous soit donnée directement c'est à
dire qu'aucune information marie voir
nos vingt autres lieux avant cet endroit
là vous êtes les des familles les
proches
vous allez être les premières personnes
vous êtes les premières pousses rd oui
ça les premières alertes et c'est une
fausse information 6
pour l'artiste au format ne voulait pas
la paix à la côte et ma femme attend
déjà bien madame pourquoi pas ses
nationaux en avant par bien des rumeurs
d impression que le temps est
interminable vague de secouristes est
loin d'apaiser ces familles inquiètes
non tu vois en attendant on nous tourner
en bourrique qua non mais c'est bon je
venais d'information
il ya beaucoup d'émotions dans ces
moments là donc l'idée c'est d'être
présents pour les soutenir
faut pas être débordée par ses
ces émotions là vraiment c'est ça notre
mission principale la mise en place
d'une écoute téléphonique avec la
préfecture permis le recensement est
ainsi de croiser les informations une
communication pas toujours facile dans
un aéroport international
m
sur la piste les entretiens individuels
et collectifs se poursuivent avec les
impliquer mais vont très bien ils vont
très bien mais c'est à vous qu'il faut
demander comment vous allez moi ça va je
suis pas plus je mange ou santé des
chiens tout cas j'ai vu des morsures way
la piste et on a pris du temps changent
mais là je vends ma tanière
d'accord vous inquiétez pas on vous
allez la voir l'idée c'est de prévenir
une pathologie qu'on appelle le syndrome
psychotraumatiques qui peut avoir des
conséquences à long terme
donc en plus de pour certains d'être
endeuillé d'avoir perdu des membres de
leur famille d'avoir vécu cet événement
pour certains ça peut être des
cauchemars des images qui se répètent à
l'infini une dépression
beaucoup d'autres choses en terme de
symptômes on est à l'ère de sable comme
parfois dans la réalité la conclusion
peut être heureuse la coordination et
surtout le système d'information dans ce
type de catastrophe
influence considérablement le scénario
qu'il faut absolument avoir ce type
d'exercice pour s'entraîner puis aussi
pour mettre en évidence qui ne va pas
pour que le jour pour ça arrive
réellement on est cette expérience pour
pouvoir justement ne pas reproduire les
erreurs et qu'on allait le faire
maintenant que le jour vraiment utile
nous on essaye d'être de prévenir au
plus tôt le dispositif vient avant que
les gens demandent mais on peut pas être
sur toutes les interventions sur tous
les événements et l'idc c'est de
sensibiliser la population au fait que
ce type d'événement peut avoir des
répercussions psychologiques qui peuvent
être importantes et qu'il faut pas
rester